[Música]
y
en ecuador el temor de la población a
enfermarse el cob it easy' 9 incidió en
la reducción del uso de métodos
anticonceptivos en comparación al mismo
período del mes de enero a julio del año
2019 64% de hombres y 54 por ciento de
mujeres dejaron de utilizar
preservativos en el año 2020 las
restricciones de movilidad del país
andino implementó durante la pandemia el
toque de khedira o el temor a
contagiarse fue la principal causa
significa que 15 millones de mujeres
podrían tener embarazos no deseados o
con necesidades de anticoncepción
insatisfechas según cifras del
ministerio de salud de ecuador a pesar
que continúan las dotaciones por parte
del estado si reconocen que existe una
reducción del 10 por ciento de la
provisión de métodos de anticonceptivos
hacia los usuarios que ahora deberán
hacer un esfuerzo mayor para fortalecer
los servicios de planificación familiar
y salud reproductiva para que al menos
80% de las mujeres accedan a métodos
anticonceptivos en el año 2020 y 2021
[Música]
en el primer semestre del 2020 el
sistema de salud pública del salvador
registró 258 embarazos de niñas de 10 a
14 años y 6 mil 581 en el grupo de 15 a
19 años si bien el consolidado es
levemente menor al del año pasado
organizaciones feministas advierten de
un importante subregistro debido a que
las denuncias por estos hechos
probablemente se redujeron con el
confinamiento de cinco meses por la
pandemia de coronavirus estas
organizaciones destacan que los
embarazos en niñas de entre 10 y 14 años
indican la existencia del delito de
violación lo que evidencia el fracaso de
los sistemas de protección de la niñez y
de las políticas de seguridad en un país
que aseguran tiene un alto índice de
impunidad en estos casos ya que los
agresores suelen ser personas que viven
cerca o dentro de la misma casa
[Música]
la pandemia de afectados también el
sector de la salud sexual y reproductiva
en áfrica se han interrumpido programas
de distribución de anticonceptivos y
también programas de tratamiento
hormonal para personas trans entonces ha
sido un impacto a nivel general se
calcula desde las naciones unidas que
ahora posiblemente unos 7 millones de
embarazos no deseados después de la
pandemia a nivel global y muchos de
ellos estarían aquí en áfrica dado que
en áfrica subshariana se han
interrumpido hasta el 50 por ciento de
la distribución de anticonceptivos en
esta región también organizaciones como
mama network que trabaja en 16 países
del continente ha dicho que han recibido
un llamado y que en un volumen que
equivale a las situaciones de conflicto
desde que empezó la pandemia hay otros
sectores que también han visto una voz
se han visto afectados en este contexto
por ejemplo el cierre de muchas clínicas
de aborto oficiales implicarán un
aumento en los abortos clandestinos que
a su vez podrían ser tiene que
significar hasta 11 mil muertes por
embarazos 9 por temas relacionados a
embarazos no deseados y entre las
comunidades más afectadas también y
pocos visibilizadas está en el sector el
fbi y las del trabajo sexual sudáfrica
por ejemplo ha implementado
de antirretrovirales en lugares
alternativos a los centros de salud pero
aunque se reconocen los derechos de las
trabajadoras sexuales no ha implementado
ninguna medida para mitigar el impacto
psicológico de salud y financiero para
este sector
[Música]